let's bring you some breaking news now
in a new yougov poll of conservative
party members has found that list trust
is the strong favorite to beat rishi
sunak in the race to be the next prime
minister well let's go live now to
westminster and to our deputy political
editor sam coats and sam a real boost
there for liz trust
that's right this is the first poll of
conservative party members that yougov
have done since we found out who is in
the last two that has to be uh that's
going to the conservative party
membership over the next few weeks and
here are the results
rishi sunak gets 38
of the
of the votes while liz truss is on 62 so
a pretty whopping lead for the foreign
secretary currently she is there for 24
percentage points ahead of her rival
rishi sunak this is an expanded lead
compared to just earlier this week you
can see that the 62 percent is up two
from a poll taken uh of tory party
members on monday tuesday uh rishi sunax
38 is down two uh compared to that poll
at the start of the week now that looks
like a very big hurdle for the former
chancellor to overcome
in the next few weeks ballots going out
in about a fortnight but look at the
toxicity of this race cap
who can't be trusted well liz trusts uh
18 of conservative party members say
that liz trust can't be uh trusted but
40
of tory party members say that rishi
sunak can't be trusted it seems like all
those stories of rishi sunak's betrayal
of boris johnson some of which stretch i
think a little bit of the
bounds of credibility and truth and the
relentless hammering he's had from some
mps and certain media outlets well
that's really rubbed off
and it makes it just that little bit
harder for the conservative party to
come back together in the event that
rishi sunak becomes prime minister at
the end of it which doesn't now look
like
the likely outcome but to give you a
sense of the breadth of uh liz truss's
support
she gets
the majority of the vote amongst people
in all age categories 18 to 49 50 to 64
65 plus
she wins amongst men she wins against
women and she wins amongst league voters
now the only category that rishi sunat
wins in is remain voters which is a
pretty remarkable turn up for the books
because of course back in that 2016
brexit referendum it was rishi sunak who
was a prominent campaigner to leave and
it was liz truss who was passionately
advocating to remain but politics uh has
turned the wheel uh has gone round and
now uh as it were uh rishi sunaka tracks
the conservative uh remain leaning vote
now liz trust has been out and about
more prominently than her rival today
let's hear what she had to say earlier
my plans do not exceed the headroom i'm
very clear that they are about 30
billion pounds worth of
worth of costings and those are
affordable within our current headroom
but what is not affordable is putting up
taxes choking off growth and ending up
in a much worse position
and many many international bodies
including the oecd say that our current
policy is contractionary it's likely to
lead to a recession and we simply cannot
afford that
so a remarkable stage in this race given
that rishi sunak was the front runner
for all the way through the mp stages
now he's the underdog and acknowledges
such in this race and we know that
because of these hugo tory member polls
i'm joined by one of the people at ugov
who does it that's patrick english um
this is a very big mountain that rishi
sunday needs to climb in order to
win this race now can you say for
certain how certain can you be that liz
liz trust is on calls for victory
well certainly right now this is just a
poll this is a snapshot of conservative
party members opinion right now however
it's very consistent with the findings
we found just a couple of days ago that
said if you look back to last week it
was penny morden who was sweeping the
board with conservative party members
the week before it was ben wallace and
if we go back as far as january rishi
sunak had a commanding leave over yes
liz truss so certainly the conservative
party membership are volatile they have
been proven to change their minds and
they will go where the wind takes them
however right now this looks like a huge
huge mountain forces tonight to climb if
the polling is anything to go by are
there any clues in the data as to why
tory party members are backing liz truss
over ishino i think there's a couple of
things yes one of the significant things
that we've been finding when we talk to
conservative party members is they're
looking for honesty integrity and a
return to conventional conservative
values so what does that mean well it's
big trouble for issue tsunak if 40 of
the conservative party membership don't
think he can be trusted it's also a big
problem i think that liz trust is able
to or is getting out on a platform and
saying she's prioritizing tax cuts
straight away a return to that reduction
in the involvement of the state in the
economy registration sunac is saying he
wants to keep taxes where they are for
now deal with inflation and then look at
tax cuts so certainly liz choice is kind
of singing from the same hymn sheet if
you like conservative item members and i
think that's costing risky sunk at the
minute with them do you think that the
data shows that there's just not enough
excitement around richie sunak's policy
program it seems like he's promising jam
tomorrow she's promising jam today is
that having an impact i think it
absolutely is yes as we say these
conservative conventional conservative
values are coming up time and time again
when we talk to the conservative party
members we let them tell us in their own
words what they'd like to see and they
were talking to us about tax cuts they
were talking about a reduction in the
amount of government spending those
exactly the sort of things that liz
trust is campaigning on right now and
that makes difficult for rishi sunak
final question the rishi suna
campaign tell us time and again that he
can beat kierstarma better than liz
trust is that true well at the minute
our current favorability ratings for
both of these politicians so the amount
of people that say they have a positive
opinion minus the amount that saying
that having negative opinion is at minus
31 each so i don't think there's much
evidence at all that either of them are
going to fare much better at the moment
but of course those that's a very
hypothetical question we have to see
much closer to the time when the public
starts to get really thinking about
general elections and who the candidates
actually are patrick english thank you
very much indeed uh that final port
critical rishi sunax team tell you he's
better place to win a general election
not clear that that's true from the
evidence
sam thank you that's sam coates our
deputy political editor in westminster
and just a reminder that in two weeks
time we'll see those two candidates go
head-to-head here on sky news in a live
televised debate k burley will be
hosting it all on thursday the 4th of
august at 8 00 pm